السادسه من فبراير اللحظات الاولى لزلزال
كهرمان مرش لحظات لن ينساها الاتراك الذي
نستيقظ على اسوء كارثه اصابت البلاد منذ
قرض
ساعات صعبه تخللها زلزال اخر زاد من عدد
الضحايا وحجم الدمار لتبدا الحكومه
ومؤسساتها باستيعاب الصدمه والشروع في
عمليات البحث والانقاذ
ولان حجم الكارثه فاق قدره البلاد سارعت
فرق متخصصه من كافه انحاء العالم الى
المشاركه في عمليات الانقاذ هكذا يبدو
المشهد بعد شهر من الزلزال مخيمات كبرى
انشات لاستيعاب المتضررين وانتشرت بابات
تعرف بمدن الخيام الصغيره في كل مراكز
المدن الاكثر تضررا
لكل واحد من هؤلاء قصته معززه ولكل منهم
راي في اداء الحكومه
كبيرا وضخما لكنني ارى ان الحكومه استجابت
بشكل جيد منذ البدايه وزعت الخيامه وحتى
اليوم تقدم ثلاث وجبات
البعض الاخر اشار الى ما سماه تقاعسا عن
تقديم المعونه وتقييم البيوت المتضرره
موظفون البلديه لم يدخلوا للبيوت بل قيموا
وضعها من الخارج دون النظر الى الركائز مع
ان البيت متضرر وفي جدرانه تشققات
فاقع عدد قتل الزلزال 45 الف شخص وتسبب في
تشريد مئات الالاف
يرى الكثير منهم ان عليه الاعتياد على نمط
الحياه هذا فعمليه اعاده الاعمار برايهم
قد تاخذ وقته
باك الحكومه لحجم فاتوره اعاده الاعمار
الضخمه التي ستشكل عبئا على الاقتصاد
لكنها تعد بان تنهي عمليات اعاده اعمار
المدن خلال عام واحد مستشهده بتجاربها
السابقه واخرها اعاده اعمار المناطق
المتضرره جراء زلزالي ازمير واليزر عمر
الحاجه الجزيره غازي عنتاب